people to understand a lot to come it's
his legacy I think you had a little bit
of about his experiences in larger
graduated law school Phi Beta Kappa
however when he was in grade school he
was placed in special education and a
teacher saw in him inquisitiveness
rather than mischief took him out of
that special ed class and put him with
he should have been he has never
forgotten that and that is one of the
things that drove him he talked about to
me about that very often there were two
things that saw the undergirded all of
our conversations that experience and
the fact that we're both PK's the
children of preachers preachers kids and
we talked about that and what that
experience meant to our growing up and
so so much of Elijah's service with
faith base and so much of it had to do
with trying to make sure the known child
ever experienced what he experienced in
grade school when he was placed in
special education when he should have
been on track to be an exceptional
student he's on the Transportation and
Infrastructure Committee and he worked
very hard in trying to improve
communities in his congressional
district and throughout the country for
that matter he was one of my go-to guys
when I needed help on rural
infrastructure projects Claridon county
where his route or rule his parents were
sharecroppers in Clarendon County before
moving away so that he would want to be
remembered for but to me
his passion for preserving this
democracy that's what he was all about
on that Oversight Committee and he had
this thing about whether or not we were
doing all we could to protect this
fragile democracy that we have and that
was a source of the animus
that the president directed toward him
because Elijah was not having any of the
president's foolishness
when they came to preserving the
Constitution of the United States